puisqu'on est confiné dans nos canapés
je vous propose de continuer à fouiller
sur les plates formes d internet et dans
les plates formes totalement gratuite
il y à une plateforme qui s'appelle
archive.org je devrais dire arxiv.org un
site américain
céline internet arxiv de deux des états
unis aux etats unis les droits d'auteur
sont pas exactement les mêmes qu'en
france
et il ya tout un tas de films qui sont
comme les livres en france par exemple
tombé dans le domaine public aux états
unis et qui sont donc disponibles sur ce
site internet arxiv alors il faut taper
à rc hybrid4 kyle point org et dans la
petite barre de recherche aux fins de
deux menus euros via une petite
pellicule et quand on clique dessus on
arrive sur un site qui évidemment cet
américain évidemment c'est des films
américains qui sont pour la plupart pas
sous titré mais on parle de films
anciens de films noirs des années 30 40
50 60 50 pas encore beaucoup 60
on parle de films muets donc de grands
films muets les signes de griffiths par
exemple sont disponibles sur ce site
les films de charlot une grande partie
des courts métrages de charlot sont
disponibles sur ce site et on trouve
également des films totalement
improbable des films contre l'usagé de
la marijuana qui dans les années 50 aux
états unis qui était un grand sujet et
jeunes contre les communistes c'est des
films qui permettent de bien rigoler
aujourd'hui parce que c'est un ton nom
une manière de faire du cinéma une
manière de regarder le monde qui nous
paraît tellement désuète
enfin en tout cas voilà c'est un endroit
dans lequel on peut aller piocher des
choses découvrir du cinéma bis du cinéma
plus sérieux ce qui était réellement le
cinéma deux films noirs des années des
années 50 40 50 des donneurs haye vol
dressed to kill enfin des films comme ça
qui sont des films mythiques dont on va
probablement un peu tous vu déjà le
titre les f
et c'est quand on s'intéresse au cinéma
et qui là sont disponibles gratuitement
il faut simplement faire l'effort
d'accepter de regarder le film dans sa
version originale en général dans ces
films là les dialogues sont quand même
pas essentiel c'est surtout pour voir la
qualité de l'offre
voilà donc je ne saurais que trop vous
conseiller d'aller fouiller dans cette
mine